It's one of the main priorities decided by
the EU leaders when they fixed the directions
for the next five years: build a European
Energy Union. It's crucial for the economy,
for Europe's security, and to fight climate
change.
An effective energy Union can fundamentally
improve the situation in Europe - by ensuring
cheap, sustainable and secure energy for all:
states, companies, and citizens.
The conflict between Russia and Ukraine, and
a row over gas prices, highlights the urgency
for the EU to increase its energy security.
More than half of our energy consumption is
imported. This costs a billion a day.
This means that we have to take measures, specially
in the current geopolitical context, to, first
of all, solve some of the problems in our
infrastructure, but also to reduce our external
dependence, specially for those countries
who are dependent on a single supplier.
The EU depends more and more on gas from external
suppliers. When gas is imported from different
sources and contracts are flexible, things
are fine, says European Council President Donald Tusk.
But most bilateral contracts with Europe's
dominant supplier Russia, are concluded on
a long-term basis, sometimes more than 20
years, and that can be unhealthy, Tusk says.
The EU's gas market was discussed by EU leaders
at their Spring summit in March.
All leaders agreed to reinforce transparency
in the gas market, so suppliers cannot abuse
their position to break EU law and reduce
our energy security.
Pooling energy resources across the EU is
another way to ensure energy security. But
in order to achieve this, renovation and better
interconnections of electricity grids and
gas pipelines are needed. So that energy surpluses
in one member state can be easily channelled
to another member state with a shortage.
Here, Europe has gone forward. Not only have
we improved the connections between member
states, but we also supported Ukraine with
reverse-flow. This shows we were right in
our view that all states should be reachable
through gas pipelines.
Recently, leaders of France, Spain and Portugal
agreed in Madrid to double the electricity
interconnection capacity between their three
countries, and to start a major gas project.
Our common European project is to unite, integrate
and connect. We already removed artificial
borders between us and we shall now remove
natural ones.
Meanwhile, in the EU's northern corner, Lithuania
opened its own LNG floating terminal in late
2014, labelled "Independence". With this terminal,
the Baltic state not only reduces its previously
100% dependency on Russia, but it can also
supply its neighbours.
Achieving 10% interconnection is the goal
proposed by the European Commission in its
Energy Union plan. It will require serious
investment.
It is estimated that in the next two decades
we will need 200 billions a year to upgrade
our current systems, not only to meet future demand
but simply also to replace the existing infrastructure.
What we need to do is give a direction to
that so that member states, market players,
make the right investments.
Investments which in turn will not only generate
economic growth and more jobs in the energy
sector, but also make energy cheaper. This
is crucial for Europe's competitiveness at a
time when energy bills are 30% more expensive
in Europe than in the United States.
Cleaner energy is a very important dimension
of Europe's Energy Union plan. The UN Climate
Change conference which will take place in
Paris this year provides a clear momentum
for a big push for more energy efficiency
and a new generation of renewables. The EU
is at the forefront of the decarbonisation
effort, and it wants other countries to follow.
I thank Europe for being first in delivering
its climate pledge for the Paris Conference."
With a target of 40% cut in greenhouse gas
emissions by 2030, the EU leads the world's
fight against climate change. The Energy Union
is the main driving force to reach that target.